ايلونا نواشنطن بنتائج جيده بنتائج سوف
تساعد حقا هناك دعوا مالي وهناك اتفاقيات
اخرى سنقول المزيد عنها لاحقا
[موسيقى]
اخبار الجزيره اهلا بكم بعد تعهد الامريكي
بارسال صواريخ باتريوت لاوكرانيا زنسكي
يؤكد لدى عودته ان بلاده تعمل من اجل
تحقيق النصر ومسكت تحذر من ارتفاع مخاطر
الصدام مع واشنطن وتقول انها ابلت امريكا
ستكون هدفا مشروعا لي ضربتها في اوكرانيا
يوسف عن مقتل ثلاثه واصابه ثلاثه اخرين
بحسب النيابه العامه الشرطه اعتقلت مطلق
النار وهو رجل 60 »
في حين تشير وسائل الاعلام المحليه الى ان
الحادثه وقعت بالقرب من مركز للاكراد وانه
هناك دوافع عنصريه لهذه الحادث نبقى في
فرنسا حيث ينظم وظفوه سكك الحديديه اضرابا
المطالبه برفع اجورهم وتحسين ظروف عملهم
في بريطانيا اضراب جديد للعاملين بالتمريض
ورئيس الوزراء يصف الاوضاع بالصعبه ويقول
لافضل ما يمكن القيام به هو محاربه التضخم
في نجاح جديد لمونديال قطر شركه فيزا تعلن
عن تجاوز المبالغ المدفوعه من المشجعين
داخل السادات في كاس العالم قطر 2022
سابقتها في روسيا بنسبه 39% اذا شهدت
المباراه النهائيه
العدد الاكبر في عمليات الشراء مقارنه
بباقي المواجهه
الى اللقاء